this star down here which says
everything I wanted but nothing I'll
ever need hello I made it up actually so
yeah I'm deep not really not really that
dude this is like my third or four so
the story behind this one every time
I've done this I've probably been at
least a little bit drunk away being one
way since everyone was going to tell you
shop and I thought I'm just gonna get
something like wherever it so I start
googling random stuff and they're like
yeah that'll be cool and the guy put me
on the front desk so I'm like lying
face-down on the front desk of the shop
and then you've put the design on and I
hadn't got the heart telling me it was
too big because I was just like nervous
he was like a big like toad like bike
ago and I was like scrubs you could get
it then I literally woke up the next
morning in the little bit but hey it's
not really remember what was going on
but I knew my arm was really hurting and
I was like no and I was like having
flashbacks of what happened the night
before I look now at my arm and I was
like oh my god and this was the only
time I ever googled like how do you
remove typos and on the nighttime we
will perform in an X Factor America this
is my singing arm I forgot it was my
microphone arms then Bangla arrows are
going up like it's all working out and
my dad was at home in the UK and turned
her to my sister when my arm came up on
the TV when I hope they're bloody
stickers I regretted it massively but I
think what you'd find with tattoos is
like for anyone in front they have a bad
tattoo or something out there like it
just becomes part of you like it becomes
like a little scar on your skin that you
keep with you and it's a story and it's
a memory of something that you did and
then funnily enough this actually became
my whole hugo fashion range logo so it
was like one of the best mistakes I've
ever made
it's like on my leg here it's like a
little cross on my ankle and across on
the other ankle screw your legs to your
feet so it keeps you grounded or
whatever it was something stupid but we
got these things was like I thought I'd
start at the ankles because I was like
kind of teasing myself into it so I
could see what it felt like before I
like went in for it probably was a
little bit of mistakes and I didn't know
I was gonna end up like this well here
we go I think next I got this time down
here which says everything I wanted but
nothing I'll ever need and it was kind
of like a place in my life where I've
gotten to a certain point of success and
it was like really really cool but it
was super lonely atmosphere whenever you
get home because you lose a lot of
different friends and wherever I was and
I was like in this amazing penthouse
that I owned but I was still sad and I
was like ah this everything I have want
to be is nothing I'll ever need because
all you ever really need is good people
around you I guess I first of all I
started thing like what kind of account
need to get something deep and
meaningful and then by that idea now
it's just gotten totally out the window
when you get to a certain point of Tears
you just kind of want to fill space I
feel like just nice pictures wherever
I'll so a lot more my tattoos now are
more pictures rather than things that
have special meanings or whatever I just
don't know I just like the artwork with
it I guess
I feel like this only time will tell
it's just like my only like dad Joe
Taylor because it goes next to my watch
which I thought was quite fun kids are
there at the time to tell him I just
start running out of ideas for different
things so I just started like throwing
loads of random stuff on me I mean I
have my initials LP which can also stand
for many other things that are also
rooted hilarious we got a bunch of roses
going on here some Eagle guys flying
away I get a lot of banners and then I
don't know what to put in the banners
but I've just kind of left space for
stuff that might mean something one day
I don't know what to do with it I'm just
I don't know i'ma just color in oh we
can I tried something new every day
actually that's a good idea like that
this one I kind of got when I was a bit
pissed off about something when we were
in the band and there was loads of like
and a muster you going on I thought it's
like the little school design thing in
us as we are the quiet ones because we
were never allowed to say anything
nobody wanted to tarnish the image of
whatever the hell was going on in the
thing so trying to hide a bunch of stuff
bleeds over into your normal life as
well as it does you plain whatever
character is you play as a celebrity or
a performer or whatever so that was kind
of like a bit of an angsty tattoo I got
the pleasure of meeting someone called
Nico petard oh he needs some sort of
like tattoo TV program but he just used
to come over to my house in LA and then
we do like I mean one sitting from here
to here was like 13 hours I'd text my
mom and the tattoo is already at the
house and I was like ah like what's my
time of birth and then she didn't answer
for like an hour so I was like just I
don't know just put on what the clock
says now whatever isn't it me to put it
on then I like it because it kind of
worked out it's like five to twelve
which five to twelve is like five
minutes to lunch time it's a great time
of day or at five minutes to pie sign
another great time of day so it all
works out up here I have like my family
coat of arms which I didn't realize
looks remarkably like Gryffindor which
also is one of my other favorite things
which works out nicely well there's a
lion in the middle and then that there's
meant to be something here my family
slogan which was like I'd rather died
and vinius grace which I thought my
family would have been absolutely
badasses back in the day which is cool
which I still have to get that written
in but the detail on this bit in
particular is just crazy
I mean Nico is literally one of the best
artists in the world so but it took ages
and it really hurt by the time I mean
getting onto the elbow like oh like a
stripper nap
Roman numerals are my exciter number but
I can't read Romans so I've kind of
stuck to tell you exactly what they are
but this was like my x-factor number
from when I was on the show I feel like
the most painful was hands but in
particular this hand I had one guy do it
and the guy completely screwed it up
and so I've had this hand in like three
times this was I think five hours just
here third and fourth hour I was like
really feeling and the last thing he
made me do it was like can you just put
your fist like this and I thought you
trying to look at it and then he was
like going into the way the knuckles are
and obviously your knuckles I like
completely over at that point it was a
[Music]
feather when I was little I read this
story after my nan passed away with my
mom and it was basically about a little
boy and the woman in the house kept
finding like owl feathers around the
house the day after I read the story I
came downstairs walked over to where the
blinds were there was this huge feather
so me and my mom kind of thought it was
my nan so I got that for my gnome which
is quite cool I've definitely need to
fill the rest of this arm up and then I
think I already want to go across my
chest and then maybe something here my
advice to people getting tattoos is that
once you start you will not stop because
there'll always be some sort of space
that you look at and go I need to get
something in handy and that's kind of
what happened to me with all of my
tattoos and I saw it online the other
day that somebody had like done a
picture of me and edited out all my
tattoos and I've always wondered like
what I'd look like without them and I
absolutely hated it so I know I made the
right choice but really make sure when
you get the first one that it's what you
want to do because once you start you
won't stop
[Music]